todo lo que nos resta por hacer es
evaluar esta integral que obtuvimos en
el último vídeo que es más bien un
ejercicio de evaluar integrales
trigonométricas más que cualquier otra
cosa pero bueno esto no le hace daño a
nadie no le hace daño a nadie un poquito
de práctica así que hagámoslo paso a
paso correcto entonces empezamos con el
seno al cubo de teta no es fácil
encontrar un anti derivada de esto así
que vamos a usar nuestras identidades
trigonométricas para poder ver si
podemos escribirlo esto de alguna otra
forma más fácil de integrar y en efecto
podremos porque por ejemplo seno al cubo
de teta lo podemos reescribir como seno
de teta seno de teta por el seno
cuadrado de teta pero seno cuadrado de
teta simplemente es sen es uno menos
coseno cuadrado de teta y esto al hacer
la distribución nos queda seno de teta
menos seno de teta coseno cuadrado de
detalles o ya es fácil de integrar
conocemos una anti derivada de seno de
teta
ok y de la otra seno de teta es la
derivada de coseno entonces podemos usar
una sustitución vámonos con el término
verde coseno cuadrado de teta pues
también lo podemos reescribir como como
un medio de uno más coseno de dos tetas
que éste ya no es tan inmediato pero
bueno se han visto los vídeos de
trigonometría me creerán que esto es
cierto y esto al distribuirlo nos queda
un medio más un medio del coseno de dos
tetas ok y eso también es sencillo de
integrar ahora nos falta la parte roja
que es a de por sí ya era sencilla de
integrar ya lo veremos con más detalle
así que lo voy a copiar tal cual esto es
menos cuatro veces el coche no de teta
más cuatro veces el seno de teta coseno
de teta
- el seno cuadrado de teta coseno de
teta de teta esto lo vamos a integrar
respecto de teta todo esto y vamos a
integrar desde cero a dos
ok este son dos muy bien entonces vamos
a hacer lo vamos a ir obteniendo las
anti derivadas de esto entonces la anti
derivada de seno de teta simplemente es
menos coseno de teta que es como la
primera parte de esto ahora quién será
la anti derivada de menos
beteta por coseno cuadrado de teta bueno
si nos damos cuenta la derivada de
coseno de teta es menos seno que aquí
justamente lo tenemos entonces podemos
hacer o igual a coseno de teta y nos
queda la integral de cuadrada por la
integral de un cuadrado escocés no es
eso al cubo entre tres y un escocés no
así que esto simplemente nos queda
coseno
cubo de té está sobre tres este es un
ejercicio simplemente de sustitución
ahora bien una anti derivada de un medio
pues simplemente será un medio de teta
correcto entonces vámonos con este otra
vez
necesitamos la integral de un medio de
coseno de dos tetas si hacemos igual a
dos teta su derivada es dos pero aquí no
aparece el 2 bueno pues vamos a hacer
que aparezca multiplicamos por 2 pero
para que no se altere todo esto
necesitamos dividir entre 2 así que este
2 se va a convertir en un 4 finalmente
que es lo que nos queda pues va a ser un
cuarto de la integral de dos veces
coseno de dos tetas que eso es seno de
seno de dos te está muy bien vámonos
ahora con la parte roja una anti
derivada de de coseno eta es seno de
teta por lo tanto esto nos queda menos
40 de teta ahora aquí la derivada de
seno de teta
coseno de teta así que haciendo una
sustitución simplemente nos queda la
anti derivada de esto es 4 seno cuadrado
de teta sobre 2 que es y dividido entre
2 y tengo este 4 pues puedo puedo
simplemente eliminar esto y ponerlo como
un dos actos ok ya que divide entre dos
muy bien y de hecho si ustedes derivan
esto pues es dos por la derivada de seno
cuadrado es dos veces seno de teta por
la derivada del seno que es cosa y no
detecta usando regla de la cadena y el 2
por el 2 nos da 4 entonces aquí pueden
verificar que esto es cierto ahora bien
vamos a restar la de la anti derivada de
seno cuadrado de teta por coseno beteta
pero otra vez la derivada de seno de
teta es coseno etc entonces con una
sustitución tendremos que esto es seno
al cubo de teta sobre 3 y ahora qué es
lo que vamos a hacer todo esto que
obtuvimos es una anti derivada
de lo que teníamos acá arriba esto vamos
a evaluarlo desde cero a dos muy bien
vamos a hacerlo poco a poco entonces
quién es el costo el coseno de dos pi
pues es uno así que vamos a tener menos
uno estamos evaluando todo en dos y
cosenos al cubo de 2 p coseno de ccoo
seno de dos pies uno al cubo pues es uno
entre tres correcto ahora vámonos con el
verde un medio
y por teta pero te 32 pi entonces
tendremos pi y ahora vamos a ver en lo
siguiente por qué
un seno de dos veces dos pies seno de 40
seno de cuatro pies cero si nos damos
cuenta aquí tendremos menos cuatro seno
de 2 piqué también es cero más dos veces
seno de dos y al cuadrado que es cero y
menos seno de dos pie al cubo entre tres
es cero entonces todo eso fue muy fácil
de calcular
muy bien hechos no calculamos nada puede
ser y a esto le tenemos que restar esta
este resultado que obtuvimos pero
evaluado en 0 entonces vamos a ver
coseno de cero es 1 y con el menos de
acá tendremos menos 1 coseno de cero es
1 al cubo es uno entre 3 es un tercio y
ahora un medio de tt evaluado en cero
pues es 0 y nuevamente seno de cero es
cero así que todos estos se cancelan muy
bien entonces simplemente ya terminamos
con esto y vamos a ver quién es
tendremos menos uno más un tercio y aquí
vamos a sumarle pi
muy bien ya le sumamos y le restamos
menos 1 entonces nos queda más 1 y le
restamos un tercio y es menos un tercio
y esto se cancela con este este tercio
con este otro y ahora sí nos merecemos
unos grandes redobles porque ya llegamos
al resultado que speed merecemos un
redoble en todo se simplificó al mismo
resultado que cuando usamos el teorema
stoxx de hecho creo que ahora fue más
fácil al evaluar la integral de línea
más que la de superficie
llegamos todo a simplificarlo al mismo
resultado que es pi